here with more former Arkansas governor
mikee Huckaby Fox News contributor Tammy
Bruce good to see you
both Tammy let me start with you yes sir
everybody I wish the country did agree
with me on every issue I just know the
political reality is they do not poll
after poll and my view has shown that
and I think there's got to be a happy
medium here and if Republicans don't get
if they don't get right on the position
and we saw that in 2020 in in
Pennsylvania mastriano had no exception
for rape incest mother's life he lost by
the largest margin to a non-incumbent
since the 1940s I I would say because of
that one issue uh many of you may know I
come from the left part of my activism
was abortion rights activism she used to
be the head of of now the national I
love that he almost forgot um but I
would disagree with you to some degree
here and now I'm a conservative now I
have in the last year become a
republican I understand these arguments
but I would would say that in fact it's
not even really about abortion Americans
you see on social media they the the
conservatives are complaining oh it's a
culture of death I understand that that
is the perspective for the pro-life but
the fact is this is actually about I
would argue empathy it's an it's an
empathetic Dynamic where women do not
wake up in the morning and say oh gosh I
hope this year I can have an abortion
what I think about is as over 70% of the
decision regarding have for the women
who have a abortions 70 to 73% is about
the economy they can't afford it they
are working two jobs and a pregnancy
would they would lose their job they
can't afford to raise a child when the
economy is good abortions go down I
worry about the woman who gets is
surprisingly pregnant and she's not
expecting it who wants that child and
has to have an abortion because the
economy that the system the swamp sets
up makes it impossible possible for her
to keep that child so when when we think
about for the pro-life it's not it's
just like with the vaccine mandates
Americans don't like being told what to
do by the government they don't want
mandates or bans or things like that and
they want a way that where they can make
decisions that really refle reflect
their values women if they get pregnant
would want to be able to keep that child
and it's difficult when you can't so I
would argue that for the Republicans and
for the pro-life Americans that this is
not about abandoning your values it's
about how do you win to make sure there
are fewer abortions it means an economy
that is good it doesn't mean Banning
something because then you're losing
that whole real issue about why women
are in this position that's how we win
this argument right now when you when
you lose in Ohio and you have a
referendum like that and Democrats get
elected there are more abortions because
the economy with will be bad like it is
right now so that's how you win this
argument and and I think for everyone uh
it it will soften the nature of the
issue it is recognizing that women don't
want to be doing this whether it's a
miscarriage or an abortion or any of
that Americans understand this but women
want to be able to do it and do it
properly let me bring in Governor huabi
when when during these election Seasons
when Democrats are demagoguing all of
these issues governor I I believe
Republicans don't respond in kind they
have got to answer to to any attack
especially if it's a lie that's number
one number two then you have this issue
of extremism those that would support
late term abortions or the the governor
Norm comment that we have from years ago
um or or infant it's at some point of
viability Americans don't support that
either I think we're pretty clear on
that that becomes infanticide If the
child is viable outside of the womb so
when it comes to parental notification
which Democrats don't want when it comes
to issues of late term abortions I think
that is a winning issue for republicans
and mainstream Americans would would
would that would resonate with
them it certainly would and I also
believe that we have a messaging issue
we don't seem to understand that we need
to quit playing defense and start
playing offense it's really hard to
score when you don't have the ball and
Republicans keep fumbling and give the
other team the ball we need to focus on
one of the things that Tammy said and
and I would say it a little differently
we need to talk about the fact that
we're not against women we recognize
that an abortion has two victims two
victims obviously The Unborn Child and
the other victim is the woman who's the
birth mother who probably got talked
into the abortion by a boyfriend a
friend a mother a grandmother maybe a
father and and the fact is we're not
wanting to punish that woman in any way
we want to reach out and and and show
her compassion and assistance maybe to
keep the baby maybe to find an adoptive
parent but never to condemn her and I
believe that the other factor that we
need to talk about how women are
exploited through an abortion they're
not told the long-term physical
consequences to their body or even the
long-term consequences to their soul and
their psyche but also we get bogged down
in how many weeks if we're going to talk
about it let's focus more on something
that everybody relates to more like the
heartbeat if your heart stops you're
dead if your heart starts you're alive
most people can understand that a heck
of a lot better than trying to argue
nine weeks 6 weeks 22 weeks we make the
mistake of of acting like we we need to
be afraid of the issue no we don't we
need to Simply say we are for life we
may disagree on exactly how we're going
to make that work but one thing we do
agree on is that when you have a a
pregnancy that's in its 8th month and
you just now decide you don't want it
then no doctor should go in and slice
that child into many many pieces and
somehow call that women's reproductive
health because it isn't healthy at all
for the baby or the mother all right
Governor huge great to have you Tammy
always great to see you thank you both
for being with us hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else